nos dicen que david tiene un podcast y
quiere conocer qué tanto le gusta el
programa a su público decide realizar
una encuesta en línea y pide a su
público que visite su página web y
respondan la encuesta la encuesta
muestra que el 89 por ciento de 200
participantes respondieron que aman su
programa cuál es la principal fuente de
sesgo en este escenario como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta y en un
momento antes de que resolvamos esto
juntos pensemos qué es lo que está
pasando aquí tenemos esta población de
su público y suponemos que la población
del público es mayor a 200 personas y
david dice que quiere conocer qué tanto
le gusta el programa a su público pero
no va a poder encuestar a toda la
población no sé a lo mejor son 10.000
personas las que escuchan su programa
aunque no nos dicen ese dato pero
digamos que la población que escucha su
programa es de 10.000 personas y david
dice quiere conocer qué porcentaje de
esta población le gusta su programa así
que se necesita una muestra pero en
lugar de elegir una muestra aleatoria es
verdadera él les pide que participen
voluntariamente le pide a su público que
visiten su página web y responden la
encuesta y este es un clásico muestreo
de respuesta voluntaria no es aleatorio
quién decide escuchar su programa y
participar en su página web e incluso
que tenga acceso a una computadora pues
no va a ser algo aleatorio de hecho es
más probable que las personas que
quieran hacer esto si esas fueran las
200 personas de la población de 10.000
que decidieron participar en la encuesta
es muy probable que estas personas de
hecho ya les guste el programa de david
y le hacen caso cuando les pide que
hagan algo las personas que no les gusta
su programa o que quizá no le hacen
mucho caso a lo que él dice es poco
probable que participen en esta encuesta
y digan sabes que david no me gusta tu
programa o podríamos tener el extremo de
las personas que no les gusta para nada
ese programa y que digan definitivamente
voy a participar en esta encuesta para
hacerles saber que no me gusta nada su
programa pero
en este caso yo creo que es más probable
que las personas que les gusta tu
programa hagan lo que les pides que
hagan y vayan a la página web y
participen en la encuesta y es debido a
esto que este 89% probablemente es un
sobre estimado del número de las
personas que realmente aman su programa
ya que es más probable que las personas
que aman tu programa entren a la página
web y participen en esta encuesta hay
otras formas de sesgo tenemos el sesgo
de respuesta cuando se pregunta algo que
las personas no necesariamente van a
querer responder honestamente o quizá la
forma en la que está expresada la
pregunta pues haga que las personas
respondan de cierta manera sesgada una
pregunta clásica sería le has mentido a
tus padres la semana pasada o alguna vez
has engañado a tu pareja este tipo de
preguntas que no todas las personas van
a querer responder honestamente quizás
no las quieran responder abiertamente o
quizás no la quieran responder
honestamente en una encuesta así que en
este caso tendremos un sesgo de
respuesta pero este no es el caso aquí
la cobertura parcial
cuando tenemos un muestreo en el que no
se toma en cuenta una parte importante
de la población en el muestreo de
respuesta voluntaria es muy probable que
no se esté considerando una parte
importante de la población de aquellas
personas que no tienen interés en entrar
a una página web pero aquí no está muy
claro que esté ocurriendo una cobertura
parcial ahora veamos otro caso quizá una
realidad alterna en donde david trata de
conocer esto pero de otra manera david
tiene un podcast quiere conocer qué
tanto le gusta el programa a su público
pero en esta ocasión decide encuestar a
las próximas 100 personas que le envíen
un correo electrónico de admiración no
todos responden pero 94 de las 97
personas que respondieron la encuesta
dijeron que amaban el programa cuál es
la principal fuente de sesgo en este
escenario pues este es un ejemplo
clásico de digamos tengo un grupo de 100
personas que están muy accesibles que ya
tengo en mi buzón de correo electrónico
pues vamos a encuestar los no es esto
conveniente pues sí
este es un ejemplo clásico de muestreo
por conveniencia y no son las 100
primeras personas que pasaron por la
puerta en donde quizás sea algo no tan
aleatorio pero en este caso son las
próximas 100 personas que le envían un
correo electrónico de admiración así que
esto es un muestreo por conveniencia y
además esto que elegimos por
conveniencia muy probablemente estén
inclinados a nuestro favor así que en
este caso nuevamente se está sobre
estimando el porcentaje de las personas
que aman el programa la falta de
respuesta se refiere a cierta cantidad
de personas que llenan una encuesta o
que responden un cuestionario y por
alguna razón cierto porcentaje no
responde o no llena nuestro cuestionario
y nos preguntamos bueno quiénes eran
esas personas quizás nos hubieran dicho
algo importante y quizá su punto de
vista no está representado adecuadamente
de entre las personas que respondieron
la encuesta y hay una pequeña falta de
respuesta aquí ya que él decide
encuestar a las próximas 100 personas
que le envíen un correo electrónico de
admiración y sólo 97 persona
respondieron la encuesta así que tres
personas no participaron en ella así que
hay cierta falta de respuesta es una
fuente de sesgo pero no es la principal
fuente de sesgo en este escenario nos
preguntan cuál es la principal fuente de
sesgo y el muestreo por conveniencia
definitivamente es la principal fuente
de sesgo aquí tres personas no
respondieron pero no tiene tanta
importancia el muestreo de respuesta
voluntaria en este caso él no le pidió a
las personas como en el caso anterior
que fueran a su página web y llenaran la
encuesta aunque bueno pensándolo bien
quizás si hay un poco de muestreo de
respuesta voluntaria ya que baja con
estas 100 personas y les pide que
participen en esta encuesta y tenemos
que 97 personas eligieron participar en
esta encuesta pero nuevamente aunque
quizás sea una fuente de sesgo no es la
principal fuente de sesgo aquí ya que la
mayoría que son 97 de los 100
respondieron la encuesta aquí el
principal problema es el muestreo por
conveniencia que nuevamente debido a
esta muestra que decir
usar por conveniencia vamos a tener una
sobreestimación importante por ello en
términos de la representación de toda la
población de su público